you
if this is your first time tuned in
these games are fast really fast will
bobsled I don't know I just coughed
there I shouldn't play c4 I was getting
a lot of slack for playing c4 the last
the last term I posted you're trying to
win quick and you're playing c4 I got a
lot of that I got a lot of slack for
that one let's throw in a check and take
any piece that goes there well not any
piece but you get the idea
structural defect if e6 queen capture
because I'm on b7 let's get a center
maybe I'll kick the knight around maybe
I like this approach though just
something simple let's get this move in
soon all right right now he was a
backward pawn so I'm exchanging it for a
perfectly healthy pawn on c5 I need a
flight square I'm gonna go with the
light square as a flight square let's go
here although I'm weakening here
mmm let's exchange tricky Knight
watch out fork here I don't like how I'm
flying this gotta be honest I want to
keep this night away do I have any Forks
what about this that's a juicy for cuz I
could take one of these with check I'm
gonna go for that definitely
I've pressure on the night in the a7
pond but I'm not gonna go astray and
grab this guy I could take there with
check let's get this night out of there
I'll put pressure on them if Knight here
let's come back over let's watch it
right here although I'm weakening my my
second rank I want to trade ok let's
let's give a check here here no matter
what I guess I'm not quite sure what I'm
doing I feel like I want to just take
the knight ok they resigned back to
tournament whoa really a couple people
have
what are they doing how do you have six
points okay let's not play c4c well I
could play c5 alright let's let's see
you get any sneak attacks on each - no
no no no no alright okay whew
Dark Star Bishop is gone there goes my
idea of h2 stuff okay and give up both
bishops bishop pair versus the knight
pair lets get him rolling my bishop
wanted wants to be on this longest
diagonal I also have the G file to play
with let's get there this Knight goes
anywhere I can grab here let's let's
pile up on that night probably not the
best idea
Knight here well I could play Bishop
there and look for made on g2 I should
get here soon I'm on the rook okay let's
go here I I'm gonna queenside castle and
double rooks on the G file look for some
sack on g3 Castle rook g4
let's take here first let's um I guess
do this there's a pin if pawn takes I
take and open up this file it looks
weird to close it up but I didn't want
this pawn push to happen I was gonna go
to g4 but now there's some tactics here
so I'll just baby step it go to g6 and
then and then double this do I have to
worry about I'll commit my bishop to
defending this pawn let's close up this
side of the board so rook over here and
then looking for maybe some sacrifice on
h4 if this Knight goes elsewhere let's
drop back pawn push I just come back
okay the Knights no longer there so I
don't have a pawn to win but let's get
my Queen over here doing something they
don't have any time no time doesn't
matter
back to tournament well what just
happened okay I have six okay everybody
up there that everybody up there has six
okay D for D for another girl with a
baby set up here just a creepy-crawler
system I guess and we might have some
tricks on h7 I'm setting it up pawn
takes okay it's already happening
I'm gonna go here no matter what kim
taek's night here Queen here this is
soon-to-be mate I'm pretty sure this is
close to being mate now it's definitely
mate King here still I played h5 and
it's big trouble they can resign or no
okay little out checkmate twelve small
lead but it's very very early on or only
five minutes in here h7 and h2 ok the
Queen is said a lot of time was wasted
there let's secure my Queen position
from Knight hops to b5 and d5 let's get
there h2 a lot of pressure no way it
wouldn't happen again
what it Bishop b7 he's a highly
inconvenient piece this Knight on g4
it's a what more is it there's a lot of
a lot of time that's wasted too well I
shouldn't have done that I should have
played here yeah I have to watch out for
forks now he's still kind of like he
can't be captured okay I'm ready to take
here and then made on h2 like I already
it's working I'm pretty sure it's
already working my Knights guarding
these oh I could take that and then here
I'm on h2 again I'm on the night as well
I just take here okay so the G files
open up I could smash through on this
square and then G - I can take okay if
they're somehow I just want to keep
Queens on the board I was more inclined
I really wanted to take just then but I
want to keep some material on the board
maybe do this break down these dark
squares we brought my Bishop to c5 this
is a weak in diagonal could grab here
I'm gonna come back pressure here pawn
push next and I'm looking for made on h1
that pawns pinned okay let's scare that
rook away I will take that okay I'm
looking for mate next that's me back to
tournament 20s
20 2012 um okay
the King Slayer maybe they'll play this
quick okay they weaken their light
squares I am going to grab that pun his
Queen here anything okay he's
unprotected alright let's get my knight
over here to defend or replace my
replace my King night okay hmm I could
do this
I think Queen here Queen trade look at
the time difference oh okay I'm okay
with this definitely if Pond takes I
have a wonderful home on d4 okay so this
is um oh this is a big blunder right
here that's definitely a big blunder
there so I'm up a piece now they have a
huge time edge but this is going to be
quite all right just open stuff up so I
could trade oh boy so let's just trade
some more now rook here close to no
matter what hard to avoid the rook trade
okay they resigned thirty twenty twenty
twenty two minutes remain
okay hi pants c5 it's much more okay
we're having here night here on Bishop
to b5 maybe I'll get the bishop here
soon probably d5 happening okay I should
be alright with this I have the bishop
here let's watch over oh just hit white
with a fork I was too quick to defend I
should have looking look for that attack
fortunately I had another move to do it
yeah this is a blunder so let's trade a
little bit and then get my knight to d4
my bishop on b7 queenside castle
probably not I don't want to I want to
keep it much more simple
I'm not material I don't want to have
any imbalance especially with regard to
King position I'm going to do this I
could have
for but I don't want to have any issues
here so what now probably Bishop d7
first I don't know if I completed that
thought but I don't want to I don't want
to do what okay I could take here
there's no there's no take with the pawn
keep f7 covered we trade 18 seconds out
no they have 18 seconds
let's hit the Queen and now let's do
that and then just f6 I guess they're
gonna double rooks I can take that with
check and I have I have g7 covered
anything
they're offering a draw I think they
meant to hit resign yeah they resigned
back to tournament forty two thirty to
thirty thirty alright should try I'm
gonna try e4 next I don't know why I
keep going with d4 Knight f3 Knight f3
Bishop f4 let's grab a tempo and
centralize and I'm gonna pick up the
light square Bishop play e4 I'm on the
night on takes Queen takes Knight if
Knight here I probably push grab some
space with tempo develop my Bishop hit
the knight on e4 and what next c5 no I
think I'm close to maybe even trapping
the night ok this move should have been
played prior to Knight c6 now I have a
secure Center let's kick this night away
my g5 is an only move I'm not gonna take
them though let's just get more pieces
involved now I'm looking to push further
and the knight has to come back to e4
and I win upon there might be something
close to happening on h7 as well 94 I
take a couple times queen h5 stuff f5 is
the next type of prawn break to look
into to help both my bishop and my rook
on f1 22 seconds I guess they know and
I'm not sure what they were thinking
there I he should have gone to that
Square
so I think f5 pond takes here okay this
is a mate one two and then three on each
seven again that h7 square back to
tournament 56:46 42:37 less than twenty
minutes deep prints we've played before
I think yeah we've definitely played
before not sure how it turned out okay
they're playing um they're definitely
reinforcing this d5 point I'll take him
right be some tricks here let's see this
is scary actually this is a little bit
too scary yeah okay is there gonna be
some trick over here I need to do this
now let's do this okay I can lock things
down now I think I don't know about my
night move any pawn move I'm gonna meet
with another pawn move just like that
and I want to just keep going there's
nothing happening here as far as I could
tell I need to open it up in some way my
knight belongs on b3 and if takes I'm
gonna take like this so I have c4 would
they really take that night I need to I
need to do something else
am I ever I'm gonna be able to take that
Bishop let's just double for starters no
not so fast I should have done this
sooner there's gonna be a sack here no
okay takes like this I open up this file
LightSquared bishop gonna do anything I
have everything sealed I could come back
over here I have the Queen side lockdown
I could have been throwing in a check
yesterday a long while ago okay let's
open things up now rook over here what's
that move doing oh okay that's this is
going to be very very difficult now
there's checks here rook checkmate soon
actually rook f2 eventually is a closed
to me there's also night here where's
the main rook here Oh Queen here that
was still available what am i doing no
the Queen's guarding there
am i doing how's my time 6.0
I got to do it like this I gotta watch
out for back rank mates they gonna move
oh my goodness back rank mate oh that is
an awful way to end
oh man what a sneak attack oh man that
one was so painful oh man
hide 700 ways to win that one and I
found a way to lose oh man that is so
painful
it really is you just you can't imagine
how painful it is really babe you can't
maybe you can look at this the king's
indian who goes down this road ah back
ranker I got back rancor right there
just player until watch out I'm throwing
the farm at black oh man okay I gotta go
for crazy town stuff anything but that
rook move I want to kick the Queen away
push here no matter what please okay
watch watch out for the main ones that's
gonna be my mantra for the rest of the
game
rest of the term watch out for the
maintenance I was so awful why did I
pick that square of any square not that
one ah ugliness man ugliness okay I
could take here and then here otherwise
if I took my bishop first there's
eventually there would eventually be a
fork on that square so let's pile up on
the knight kick the Queen away remove
the defender of the night I can also
consider this pool if I probably should
have done that first keep the pin is the
play in less than 10 seconds I got
really nervous with that game to when I
saw no there's a check here but okay I
come over just watch out for the minute
ones really
I got really nervous when it was 6.7
seconds I got really nervous
okay back to tournament I'm still in
striking distance D prints 7670 was that
good the guy that beat me was that deep
prince that got me good right there with
that matin Warner that back rank you
know that's not close out from being
like a scholars mate you know chess 101
land all right
if takes I'm gonna take like this let's
pin the night and then throw my knight
in here and get on these two squares all
right let's jump in if here no I could
take the knight and then take this pawn
I really don't want to take the knight
now at the end I lose g7 all right let's
get the d5 break-in mmm let's chop and
then go here whoa
really okay watch out for each seventh
stuff I'm just gonna make sure there's
never amazing one that's the plan oh
there's that move though okay I'm gonna
take the bishop and then take here watch
out for the maintenance what is going on
I guess I'll take like this get here my
bishops gonna get on this diagonal and
he's gonna be a pest that Bishop oh it's
close to being a mate and won again
watch out for the pins bishop here
that's a check no it's not
I dropped my queen I dropped my bishop
huh I thought that was a check oh no oh
no I got a run like crazy this is a
losing position a very very losing
position I need to be a mouse artist
that is a terrible move oh my king going
running like a chicken without his head
you never want to do that ever get the
rook on the seventh I mean I could get
forked rook here I'm on that square
there goes a bishop eight point seven I
got a time my time bar my way to victory
somehow you got to just go fast hope he
doesn't play here seven point one
seconds oh boy
grab that pawn he's playing fast
I'm not playing fast enough to check
here um am I gonna get made it can i
push
I gotta go fast King here King here look
there how are we doing timewise
how we doing timewise oh my goodness I
want a time that's all I ever ever Oh
let's see if I could play a good chess
game stay tuned this guy might want he
might play a good chess game eventually
oh it just goes from bad to awful bad
awful bad to awful yes
take care I get play against this guy ah
okay
let's throw my knight in here and be a
pest right here night here okay all
right I want to kick this night before I
play f4 okay we'll go with this I guess
I guess pawn push whoa what's happening
over here
scary stuff Queen here Knight here watch
out for h2 Queen trade 33 seconds I got
a play faster get this Knight out of
here he's a pest my knight is close to
trapped baby all right
if Queen what am i doing could I move oh
there's that's a this is a very good way
to drop upon okay yeah the Queen takes
Knight is and that's a great Premal
right there right that is a wonderful
pre move my knight is a monster though
that's that's one good thing he is
watching over h2o okay let's do this
we're gonna have a queen trade Queen
trade please it's gonna happen
yes okay where's the back rancors back
rancors it's throwing a check just for
fun I'm on the rook okay
back with me um okay here I guess I'm
okay with trades I have an extra pawn
over here
get behind the Bihar
and the pond in push king position King
position not just yet let's go King
position right now make sure he's not
sneaky with grabbing that pond here
probably no matter what here probably no
matter what rook here I'm okay with
trades okay I think we're doing all
right now time wise position wise it's
fine you got to take here okay they're
down on time back to tournament 136 this
this is the guy who beat me isn't it I
gotta get him back he wasn't that good
the guy maybe I have the wrong guy I
know I played him though okay dark
square weakness on d4 what's this queen
up to she's gonna get hit with the tempo
or maybe even this Bishop let's hit the
Queen with tempo right now and then push
if she goes back home I'm gonna pin the
knight if it's challenged I might want
to just stack here yeah I'm gonna go for
it oh I got the Queen that was that was
good
let's take so it's uh directing some
play I want to throw a punch at my
opponent oh he's gone maybe I could get
a quick win just open up I want to play
b5 let's try it again
take care okay it's crumbling it's
definitely crumbling made here sneaky
I'm gonna miss it crashing through on
this square I could take that first get
back here same idea again another rook
anything why was I waiting forever right
there
I was waiting forever at that point
Bishop here and then Queen here Wow Wow
my queen can't go there finally finally
that took forever back to terminal 128
1:56 I gotta catch this guy man eight
minutes left I need to be sneaky there
he's got 13 out of 13 156 128 okay maybe
I should try scholars made stuff can I
really get that no e six shuts that down
let's stop it let's stop b5 there's
maybe a tempo against the Queen I might
want to go for that
go for it maybe they're in premium as
well alright let's open stuff up
anything the night is hit okay I'm on
this square here if the bishop moves
okay this could end quickly
this really could end quickly here with
whoa got stuff on f2 but I'm on the
Queen this is quick resigner here and
then here this is a cool matin something
here Podesta block um I guess I take
like this here this isn't the most
convincing I should have probably taken
on this square the bishop is hit Bishop
f8 Queen takes here is main they can
resign they resigned back determine one
fool man 176 149 148 124 who bobsled 7
minutes remaining
oh yeah you're really gonna get a quick
win playing like this you're really
gonna get quick win let's close it up
yeah okay
my Knights gonna do a little dance over
here to the Kings side here he goes
that's the fancy dance
h4 9 h5 Knight f4 maybe maybe one day
I'd like to exchange dark square bishop
what's wrong with um can I get this in
what's wrong with that 4 there might be
something here oh there is go for it
I got something and brewing on h2 maybe
look out look out open up that H file
you know you want to take that night
power of suggestion I'm threatening a
mate in three the bishop has to come
back here it was missed
no the bishop could come back oh I
miscalculated the bishop could block on
g2 that would have been awful I put a
bit down a full rook if that bishop
wasn't on e3 oh I would have great
things lined up all right um I guess
we'll try this
it's a horrible move or is it
yeah probably is what
my doing I'm dropping pieces night here
night here there's got to be something
good here
I don't even know what that me was doing
oh okay what's disrupt doing yeah that
really worked out well with this b5
advance alright he's a nap in the night
can't move and take with check this
bishops pinned
I wonder looking back how many different
mates I missed on this one alright I
probably here no matter what
alright here no matter what here no
matter what
anything no time back to 10 with 168 196
one 196 169 168 uh okay
they resigned back to tournament quick
boost that's a plus 10 178 196 I could
catch that guy there's not that move
less than five minutes remaining
come on okay stay focused here stay
focused you could do it you could do it
you could do it Queen c7 line something
juicy up over here on h2 well I not kind
of go for this sneak artist tactics h2
alright I'll take the dark square Bishop
that's the best I could get but I could
still move forward with this I can still
move forward let's let's plant my pieces
on these weakened dark squares 'if I've
in particular pond push I do this
alright and now maybe come back here h2
the bishop has to move moved let's get
this diagonal opened f7 incase of that
stuff okay
the Queen is tied down to the defense ah
this game is not gonna end any time soon
okay I mean it's still better for me
just this Bishop you cannot put a price
tag on this Bishop right here rook takes
here pressure on c4 if pawn push I get
that grab here come back over King up I
don't need to castle pressure on b2 this
is not a fast win at all pressure on b2
although that pounds gonna fall rook
rook to d1 I take the knight okay
some mate still something over here pin
the bishop I want to get on this
diagonal can I open this up okay pawn
push I'm gonna take like this pawn push
pawn okay I got the they got the RIP
pinned attack the rook its mate trap to
mate threat its mate soon maybe no
that's not me ah there's a pin there I'm
grab the h2 pawn I'll grab the h2 pond
at least alright okay they they're down
on time 216 that took forever it's three
minutes remain I still have an
opportunity maybe maybe 198 198 come on
less than three minutes remain
okay e4 I wonder if that's if that guy
slips up that guy needs to slip up I
definitely need to win this one maybe
one more is my opponent gonna go for
something over here
maybe yeah let's just stop that I don't
know if it's better h4 h 3 I give that I
give this square up let's just take here
trade our scribe bishops I guess let's
kick him around actually 94 this is uh
this is very aggressive of hitting the
bishop I'm gonna get rid of that night
mmm okay well what's the trick if Knight
takes maybe I go Bishop here let's go
here actually right now I don't care
about my b2 pond they gave up their dark
squares at the end of it I have a fork
if takes here let's trade maybe I get at
the back rank when I kick this night
away again I have this that was a very
key move it's Fork so I have the dark
squares under complete control take the
knight okay I'm on the rook how do they
get out of this how do they get out of
this position okay they're a little bit
of breathing room there I want to keep
my Bishop right here because it renews
back rank mates
let's stop any rook activity okay I'm on
that they might resign they might resign
and they're not resigning
should they resign why was it taking so
long to make that move okay double check
let's just do
this it's not the fastest they're in
check and it's not ending anytime soon
Bishop here
they keep creating new homes for the for
their king
okay let's stop let's make sure there's
not any stalemates right here right here
and here oh that took forever to 18 to
36 I could still catch that guy only one
minute remains only one minute I gotta
throw in a very cheap trick a very very
cheap trick let's see let's see take a
pond maybe yeah look at how cheap this
is this really is cheap this is super
super cheap really is what can you do
okay I'm winning some material here
although there's gonna be something
dangerous happening on this Square and
then f7 oh boy oh I could take with the
Queen okay let's go here
I guess I'm hitting the bishop and stuff
this pawn is pinned there's no f4 to
defend the bishop would they resign if
they're down 19 seconds remain can I get
a mate please anything fast quickly
anything fast quickly come on eh for fro
the eight from each pawn when in doubt
to throw that H pond are they gonna move
are they gonna resign they're letting
the clock tick it says it's completed
gotta keep going take the knight made on
each 200 thanks for playing
no confetti for you no soup for you ah
man that's well that's painful nope not
even any confetti ah man I should just
end this stream right now if I'm not
gonna get confetti that's clearly what
it's all about
oh man good games I'm kept that last
game in what I even overtaken that guy
would've I would have ah man that that
really set me back though right because
that loss instead of going forward
honey you go back to oh that really bit
me good